is horrible replacement therapy, BHRT.
So BHRT stands for bioidentical formal replacement therapy.
Is this bad if you've had breast cancer?
Well, bioidentical formal replacement therapy,
there is a non-bioidentical formal replacement therapy.
So if you just went to your medical doctor and asked
for formal replacement therapy,
there's a lot of medication market that are not bioidentical
hormones, and they can be extremely dangerous.
I'm very much against it.
I don't even know.
There's that many doctors that prescribe that anymore.
It just increases the risk of cancers of hormone-driven cancers
to immensely.
So I don't personally, I haven't heard anybody taking that
for a while, though I'm sure it's prescribed on a daily basis.
Bioidentical formal replacement therapy
is kind of taking the place of that.
It's said to be more natural, and it is.
It's a much healthier substitute for the medication
formal replacement therapy.
But the negative is that you still have
to really be careful if you have a formal driven cancer.
Even if you had breast cancer that was triple negative,
I still wouldn't be an advocate of using a formal
replacement therapy bioidentical, even.
It's not to be really careful.
The thing to do is to run a Dutch test,
and you'd have to keep an eye on that on a very regular basis
if you're going to do that.
Now, there's times where using bioidenticals
can be beneficial using some progesterone,
or using some testosterone.
You'd have to be more careful with the esterones
because of even if you have triple negative breast cancer,
because it is the bad estrogen,
you're going to be, if you're taking an estrogen,
the chance that it's going to occur,
you only one step away of it breaking down
into four hydroxyestero, which is the more dangerous estrogen.
You'd also want to look at your COMT genes as well,
because if you have defects on your COMT genes
and about a fan of doing a bioidentical
hormone replacement therapy and all,
because you do increase your risk for a breast cancer,
even if you haven't had a diagnosis.
So it's something you want to be careful with,
but there's a lot of doctors, especially on the West Coast
that are really big to doing bioidentical foremodes,
and it's very common to keep a person feeling younger
in many ways.
And I'm not saying that it doesn't have benefits,
but it also has risks.